all right everybody
we are live this is the reuben report
direct message
and boy oh boy you know on thursday when
i said goodbye to you guys because we're
doing this show on tuesdays
wednesdays and thursdays i didn't
realize
that the president was going to get
coronavirus then apparently beat
coronavirus
everybody was going to have a meltdown
about the whole thing and a whole bunch
of other stuff was going to happen now i
probably should have realized that
that was going to happen or something of
that magnitude was going to happen
because it does seem
that every day gets more bizarre
and there's no news that is too crazy
than the day before but literally i mean
the president getting coronavirus uh and
then already being back at the white
house i mean i was i was here on
thursday
right it's only tuesday like just
bananas so obviously we're gonna mostly
be talking about
trump and coronavirus and is he immune
as he implied
and what happened and perhaps more than
anything else what we'll focus on
is just the absolute
journalist implosion that was happening
on twitter and elsewhere i mean these
people who are supposed to be impartial
who are supposed to
defend the truth who are supposed to
help us
navigate through the morass of insanity
and it's like
yeah you guys failed i mean just
watching people have absolute nervous
breakdowns
which it's very important by the way
that i say right now
that jennifer rubin at the washington
post
she spells it r-u-b-i-n but as i have
had to tweet out
many many times and she was one of the
ones having the biggest
sort of mental breakdown over the trump
thing and then what was happening at
walter reed and then he went in a car
with people and then he got in a
helicopter and everything else
we are not related i i've done 23andme
i've done ancestry i could hire private
investigators i suppose i've been to big
family things
uh on my dad's side the reuben side of
the family we used to do this
this giant cousin club thing i'd meet
hundreds of people
you know that i'd see once a year she
was never there as far as i can tell
there is no relation and i just it's
very important that i put that out there
because
there's a rumor going around online that
she's my sister
and it's it's starting to cause my
sister to have my actual sister to have
anxiety issues so no she's not my sister
we are not related uh and
you know as i tweeted out the other day
i may have to
fight jennifer rubin in a
thunderdome type situation two reubens
enter one reuben leaves and whoever
survives gets to keep the reuben name
because this is this is
just a mess anyway so we're going to
talk about
uh trump and a couple other people at
the white house
uh getting coronavirus trump is
obviously back already we're gonna play
a little bit of the video when he
returned and just the
mental breakdown that so many
journalists and other people
were having and then i want to do two
other stories for you that i i thought
were interesting one of them's
uh kind of personal to me uh and it sort
of went underreported i actually only
saw this on breitbart maybe it made it
to somewhere else
but larry elder you guys all know larry
elder larry was so
integral as uh a huge piece of
my political awakening you know there's
there's the moment that you guys have
probably all seen and i wrote about it
and don't burn this book when i talked
about systemic racism and i was just
sort of a factory settings lefty at the
time
and larry elder just beat me senseless
well larry elder has been appointed to
the trump administration he's now going
to be working with the white house
so i want to talk a little bit about
that we're going to throw to the old
larry eleanor clip because i know you
people love seeing me beat and senseless
and then finally here in california
as if things aren't going poorly enough
gavin newsom a man who is much better at
getting haircuts
than he is at governing he has put forth
a policy
that he'll he's hoping to get past which
uh which would leave
the rest of us paying for reparations
well i guess he would be paying for
reparations too
um i never owned slaves nobody in my
family owned slaves
a lot of my ancestors were programmed
and holocausted throughout the world
i don't see why i should have to pay
reparations i don't see why anyone
should have to pay reparations unless
you
if you currently own a slave then you
should probably have to pay reparations
but i don't think anyone's guilty for
their father's sins or certainly not for
their grandfather's sins or
generations way way way way back so we
will dissect
that as well but before we get to it
people i want to talk to you about
second thoughts
uh i mentioned second thoughts last week
so first off uh the guys who created
this board game they're they're fans of
the show
and one of the ways you guys can help
fight the mob is by supporting things
that
you know support the things that you
like so we actually played second
thoughts it's a really really fun
party game and it's sure to be a hit for
your friends and family on game night
the play of the game calls for each item
to be quickly
each team to quickly create a list of
words for their opponents to decipher
leading to hilarious but puzzlement and
laughter
simply put it's a classic word guessing
game with a unique twist that allows
players to personalize
their content with their voluminous
sense of word smithery
or just their witty and warped
imaginations each round of second
thoughts is a hilarious high speed
attempt to stump the other team
both teams create a list of five things
using the letters revealed from their
colored dice
be witty and wise but don't take too
long because time is not on your side
the amount of time it takes your team to
create the list is exactly how much time
your opponents get to guess them
second thoughts the quick thinking verse
fast talking did i get it right there
there we go
verse fast talking party game get yours
today at second thoughts the game dot
com that's second thoughts the game dot
com
or your local target store and now back
to me
doing the show hello here i am okay so
let's talk about trump and coronavirus
so a couple days ago
i was suddenly i was sitting there i was
actually watching seinfeld on hulu
that's pretty much all i'm watching
these days it's just like a lot of crap
coming out of hollywood so i just watch
the same i literally watch the same
stuff that i watched in 1989 i watch
the golden girls and seinfeld and the
simpsons that's
pretty much it although i did watch um
raised by wolves on hbo max did any of
you guys watch that it's really
interesting sort of sci-fi
show by um what's his name who did alien
it's by the guy that did alien whatever
his name is i'm blanking on his name for
a second
um and uh and there's it's an
interesting thing about going to another
planet and a war that was started
between
atheists and believers the whole thing
uh i do watch that but anyway
i'm sitting there and i'm watching
seinfeld and next thing you know my
phone is blowing up and everyone's going
trump's got corona trump's got chronic
trump's got corona i thought
all right this can't be real it's got to
be a hoax or something i go on twitter
i see the tweet by the president he's
got the corona
so let's just talk about um
a little bit of just before we get to
the reaction part let me just talk a
little bit
about the fact that he he got covid
corona whatever you want to call it at
this point
um look the guy's been out there he's
been doing rallies
um he's not a big fan of the mask from
what i understand at his rallies
they take your temperature and then
masks are voluntary usually when you see
videos most people
are wearing masks as we know from
the information we've gotten from the
cdc and the who
and from dr fauci and everything else
it's like sometimes people say the masks
work sometimes
they don't work etc etc i think it is a
wise move if you're going to be in a
crowd
to wear a mask unfortunately you know
i've been telling you guys how i think
really what's happening right now is
that we're in a reality war and partly
is we don't we don't trust our experts
anymore
and part of the reason for that is well
i could directly connect this to so much
of the media
but we don't really trust our experts
because people say oh wear masks and
they say don't wear masks then they say
stand six feet then they say it doesn't
matter six feet
then they tell you when you see masses
of people rioting
and and protesting you know the black
lives matter crew and the antifa
crew they tell you oh it's fine that
they're out there and then they'll show
you a trump rally
and say it's a super spreader event so
like everything
has just been sort of left for to our
own devices and and
in a weird way i actually don't think
that that in and of itself is that
terrible i think
you have to make decisions for yourself
and for your family and especially if
you're a parent for your children or
even if you have elderly parents i mean
you have to make decisions in your life
to go about
living your life the idea that just
because
a politician tells you this is exactly
what we're going to do and that's
exactly what's going to keep you safe
again these were the same people
who back in march said oh we need two
weeks
to flatten the curve remember and then
we did flatten the curve
and now we're in you know what month six
month seven
of endless lockdowns and everything else
i saw quite a
spectacular thing that the local
the california state government put out
which is a guideline and they used a
fancy infographic you've got to have a
fancy infographic
they put a fancy infographic and they
said if you go out
to eat with your family you should eat
meaning you should chew then when you're
done put the mask back on wait a little
bit
and then you should take the mask off
and chew again i mean
while you're with your family at a
restaurant it's all bananas there's no
science behind any of that i'm not
sitting here saying
that it's a hoax or anything else um but
i think partly the the conflicting
information we're getting on all this
stuff
is is part of the problem so in any
event trump announces that he has
coronavirus and surprise surprise
the litany of of blue check people on
twitter that were wishing him
death and and this is karma and thank
god that it's going to happen
and then just like the endless
conspiracy theories he doesn't really
have it he gave or he gave it to himself
for sympathy like just the endless stuff
and you know they're always saying the
people on the right
are conspiracy theorists they don't
believe in science blah blah i mean it
was just
just all sorts of banana stuff there
were a couple people
um on the left um i think tulsi gabbard
was probably the best one who really
sent out a tweet that seemed genuine and
full of uh sympathy in wishing the
president well
uh but you know there were there were a
bunch from from mainstream politicians
that they don't they don't read as true
because
when they're being sympathetic because
if you've run around i i don't know how
many times i have to say this but i
it's bears repeating if you run around
calling someone
hitler let's pretend let's pretend for a
second we have to pretend because i
don't even think they believe it but
let's pretend for a second
that all the people who believe that
trump is hitler let's pretend
that they believe it okay they don't but
let's just pretend it
well if they actually believed it if you
found
out if this is 1941 germany and you
found out that trump or that hitler in
effect
had a uh potentially lethal disease
you would be pretty freaking thrilled
you wouldn't be sending out
disingenuous tweets saying oh i hope he
gets better you'd be sending out oh
i hope he dies now a lot of people did i
hope he dies and he's getting what he
deserved thing
but when you see these people i saw like
rachel maddow tweeted out
a thing you know basically a sympathetic
whatever and it's like yeah that is nice
like i suppose that's nice this is also
someone who for years was pushing a
russia conspiracy on the president who
spread
misinformation about the president um
and who routinely calls him racist and a
white supremacist than the rest of it
so you know i get it everyone's playing
their own little games related to all of
this
anyway trump gets to walter reed medical
center
um he actually did a video from walter
reed where he wasn't as as
tan as usual which then i saw a vox
reporter
saying he must be even sicker than we
thought because look what he looked like
at the uh the debate a few days ago
versus look what he looks like now
obviously this person has never heard of
self tanner or whatever it is that trump
uses
uh there's also something called makeup
you're not going to believe this guys
but before
we do this little show here the little
dave rubin show
my guy whacks me in the head with a
little powder all it does is get rid of
the shine but people on camera usually
put on makeup
or powder or something like that so
obviously when you watch trump i mean
trump's not denying that he's doing
something to color him orange
although at the debate i thought he was
a little more red than usual um
and then you know he's at the hospital
and he's not in makeup
but he must be much sicker it's like man
you guys are just terrible
that was a vox journalist by the way it
doesn't matter who he is
um so look trump gave a little
little video talk there he said we're
fighting it and i'm
feeling better already and that he was
on some experimental stuff so i want to
find out more and i think we will find
out more of the next few weeks
about what kind of experimental stuff he
was on because if they were able to take
this 74 year old man who's obviously a
bit overweight
doesn't have the greatest diet right
everyone knows he loves mcdonald's and
everything else
if they were able to take this guy and
get him in and out this quickly
and and all that well then we should
probably know a little bit more about
the experimental stuff
anyway a lot of people wishing him death
as i said before my non-sister jennifer
jennifer rubin from the washington post
had a complete mental breakdown and that
walter reed should be defunded
and then what trump did was there were a
lot of people that came out and
uh supported you know they were they
basically had a rally outside of walter
reed medical center
and uh trump actually got in a mask and
he got in an suv and he waved to people
they were very
excited and then you know all the usual
people oh he's going to spread it again
and what about the people in the car and
everything else but i thought masks work
he was wearing a mask i mean everything
again it doesn't really matter what side
of this you all
you all fall on or how effective you
think masks are
or social distancing or the rest of it
you know the idea that the president
was trying to be out there sending out a
positive message that that just seems
positive to me
that's not even a pro-trump rah-rah
thing it's like we all
well i can't say we all most sane people
would like to know that their president
is healthy is fighting this thing and
that he went out there and
you know uh helped the people that were
out there supporting him that he helped
them feel good about what was going on
and then by extension everyone watching
i i think that's pretty good
uh anyway he got back to the white house
yesterday which was quicker than most
people thought
and then he uh he gave a talk he gave a
little talk up on a balcony
and he took his mask off people were
very upset but we're going to throw
to the video of trump and his message
after having coronavirus let's go to the
videotape
i just left walter reed medical center
and it's really
something very special the doctors the
nurses the first responders
and i learned so much about coronavirus
and one thing that's for certain don't
let it
dominate you don't be afraid of it
you're going to beat it we have the best
medical equipment we have the best
medicines
all developed recently and you're going
to beat it i went
i didn't feel so good and two days ago i
could have left two days ago two days
ago i felt great like
better than i have in a long time i said
just recently
better than 20 years ago don't let it
dominate don't let it take over your
lives
don't let that happen we have the
greatest country in the world
we're going back we're going back to
work we're going to be out front
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger to it but i had to do it
i stood out front i led nobody that's a
leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
and now i'm better and maybe i'm immune
i don't know
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentarily
thank you very much and walter reed what
a group of people thank you very much
all right so that was president trump on
a balcony
without a mask and people were freaking
out there's an incredible video
actually of a uh a cnn journalist
where she sends out a tweet basically
saying trump's getting everyone sick you
know he's around people with no masks
blah blah blah
and then somebody found a video of her
in the white house press room
where the second the spokesman gets off
stage she takes off her mask and she's
with everyone else so everyone's
doing some level of of hypocrisy there
anyway i i thought that trump said a
couple really interesting things
uh now now before i even get into what
he said they they made this big sort of
overly produced almost like michael bay
style video of the helicopter taken off
and the helicopter landing and him
walking and
and everything else and and you can say
that's all theater
um or it's it's designed to inspire
people
or it's propaganda you can say whatever
you want about that i don't have a
problem
with those things and and we know of
course if obama did the exact same thing
the media would love it in this case
it's trump they hate it okay that's fine
but he did say a couple interesting
things he said don't let it
dominate you which i thought was
interesting um
because you know there's such a culture
of fear right now
and again 200 000 people have died this
is this absolutely is not nothing
and as i said before i think it's up to
you to figure out the best way to go
about your life
i think that the endless lockdowns
there's a very famous restaurant in la
that's within walking distance of my
house
that we just noticed closed the other
day
and it's been here for probably three
decades something like that and it just
closed and for weeks
when we drove by it i've been saying how
how much longer can they stay open
because they only have
uh you know about six tables they can
put outside it's la
you know it's like you don't have a lot
of space to work with so it's like what
restaurant could stay open when you can
only feed about 12 people at a time
nobody can
so it's up to everybody to decide
whether they want to keep their
restaurant or close it or
how you want to treat your patrons if
you have a restaurant or how you want to
you know treat your employees what your
what your policies are i would much
rather
put that back in the hands of the people
but i thought that the
the line don't let it dominate you um
was was sort of interesting like we do
need like to feel a little braver about
this like we feel very
fearful about everything i feel like
everyone's walking around
we're fearing neighbors because of their
different political beliefs we're
fearing that people are
are you know going to attack us and it's
just
we need to to be something positive he
also said that that he took a risk that
there's a risk
and that you know when he wasn't feeling
well and that there was a risk when he
went out
and everything else and that is true and
it's something that we don't talk about
honestly about
uh honestly enough meaning that there's
always risk when you when you walk
outside of your house
and you go to get your mail you could be
hit by a car
right like a dog could bite you you
could be struck by lightning a tree
could fall out on your
fall on your head i'm not trying to
freak out but bad things happen right
like there is risk in life
when when insurance companies
give you an insurance plan what they do
is look at your age
your health your habits all of those
things that's what actuaries do
and they come up with a calculation and
then and then they say well this
is this person because of their behavior
their history their family history
whatever is more risky so we have to
charge them more money
risk just exists this idea that we can't
do
anything until there is no risk
that's risky that's the risk that i'm
worried about because we're giving up
something that's very human
this this idea that we're just slowing
down the entire world
um he did say a sort of funny line he
said possibly i'm possibly immune to it
which of course everyone's latching on
to that
that's just a standard trump thing uh
you know
whatever is he immune to coronavirus i
mean i suppose some people could be
immune to it but he was sick so i'm not
exactly sure how he could be immune
and then and then this idea that he said
i'm your leader and he said it more than
once and i can understand why certain
people would hear that and say oh that
sounds
a little dictatorial but the president
is the leader and i think that the
president's sort of
mapping and i think this is what trump
is good at the president sort of mapping
how we can all kind of move forward
is good so meaning i'm the president i'm
your leader
i took the risk and and here i am
i'm better you'll get better let's try
to open things up i think it was
it was all good anyway we watched a lot
of heads implode and everything else
but uh you know i think i think
everything's gonna be okay
and i actually think i'll just say one
other thing then we're gonna move on to
the next story
um i think one of the interesting things
here is that you know
trump during the debate and i said this
while i was tweeting the debate and i
said this in my in my post thing about
the debate
is that he was very jumpy and he wasn't
that presidential and it's one thing to
be jumpy and
and attacking the moderator and
everything else when you're when you're
the outsider but when you're the
president and this is this is going to
be tough for trump for sure
i think he has to be a little more a
little more humble a little more
presidential
in his presentation during the debates
and i suspect
that after coronavirus he's going to
have a little bit
of that humility so i i think there's
there's a win in there
uh for trump and and just generally one
last thing on the media
you know it's like man guys you're
supposed to report on things
you're supposed to you know he took off
his mask on the balcony
and andrea mitchell from nbc news she
posts the video of it and she says all
right
she posted an image of it and she said i
have no words
and it's like he's standing on the
balcony balcony alone
and even if someone was behind him or
there's a secret service person there
and they have a mess then it's okay
and if they're more than six feet it's
just like i have no words
like i wonder are you a democrat or a
republican andrea i wonder anyway
before we move on to the second story uh
today's direct message
is brought to you in part by bowling
branch sheets
i love these sheets people they sent me
some and they're spectacular what do
millions of americans and three
former u.s presidents have in common
they all agree that bowl and branch
sheets are the softest
and most comfortable pure organic cotton
sheets on earth
bowling branch cotton is rain fed
pesticide free and carries the highest
organic certification
that's why it's so soft and it is soft i
promise you it is soft
because they work with family-owned
mills all over the world to expertly
weave every set of ball and branch
sheets with the highest level
of craft craftsmanship it's quality you
can feel the moment you open the box i
love my bowl and branch sheets i'm
telling you these things are
people have sat in my bed we've had
people over they've sat in the bed
you know people say oh the bed looks
nice they sit in the bed they go those
are soft sheets i think i just became
trump right there
uh and they sell directly to you guys
bowling brand sheets start at just
160 bucks their thousand dollar quality
for a fraction of the price
plus you can sleep on them for a month
absolutely risk-free and right now
you'll get 50 off any sheet set at
bowling
branch dot com that's right fifty
dollars off any sheet set
at bowling branch dot com just use promo
code ruben that's b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code ruben for
fifty
dollars off restrictions may apply see
bowlingbranch.com for details
and now back to the show hello i'm back
okay
i wanted to talk about uh larry elder
for a moment
because larry elder you guys all know
larry elder he is the conservative radio
talk show host uh he is the sage of
south
central and larry of course has played
an absolutely pivotal role in my
political evolution
and we've become good friends uh i'm
going to throw to a clip real quick
of larry many of you have seen this
we're just going to do a minor clip of
this i wrote about it in my book
but larry was pivotal in my in my
political awakening
and uh this clip is from about five
years ago i still considered myself
a progressive and a lefty and the rest
of it
and i brought up systemic racism while
talking to larry elder
and larry elder was ready to talk about
systemic racism with me
here we go so but you wouldn't not
acknowledge that there are
some systemic issues give me an example
tell me what you think the most
synthetic
racist issue is what is it well i would
say that
because black people in most cases in
many cases
were descendants of slaves that racism
as a
as an institution that it just a certain
amount of it just exists
2015 give me the most blatant racist
example you can come up with right now
um i think you could probably find
evidence that in general cops
are that cops are more willing to
shoot if the uh perpetrator is black
what's your data then white what's your
basis for saying that last year look i
know a lot of people would say look
what's going on in china i know what
they would say i'm talking about what
the facts are 965 people were shot by
cops last
last year and killed four percent of
them were white cops shooting unarmed
blacks
in in chicago in 2011 21 people were
shot and killed by cops
in 2015 there were seven uh in chicago
which is the third black a third white
and third hispanic 70
of the homicides are black on black
about 40 per month
almost 500 in the per year last year in
chicago
and 75 of them are unsolved where is the
black lives matter on that
the idea that a racist white cop uh and
shooting unarmed black people is apparel
to black people
is bs it's complete and total bs
and and the reason for these so-called
activists saying this
is the assumption that racism remains a
major problem in america the media cnn
especially msnbc
runs down whenever a black cop shoots
somebody uh and it
and it's some some march on washington
it's ridiculous
uh black people half the homicides in
this country are committed buying
against black people last year there
were 14 000 homicides
not talking about suicides i'm talking
about homicides
half of them were black 96 percent of
them black on black of that 7 000.
where's the black black lives matter
people on that
ah we were just kids god that feels like
a long time ago that was back
in early 2014 so that's uh no no not
2014 sorry that was early 2016.
um so that's just over four years ago i
mean it feels like an
absolute it feels like another life to
me
and i'm thrilled that that was the
beginning um
just one other thing on that story and
again this is in my book and i know you
guys
many of you have heard this before but
right after that we were at aura tv at
the time
it was before i was fully independent
and i went into the green room after
that
the control room and there were many
producers there and things
and everyone said oh dave don't worry we
can cut that we'll edit it out don't
worry
and i don't know why i did it but i said
no if we're if we're doing a real show
if we're doing something that's going to
be true and honest and real then then we
got to leave it in
and it was my best and worst moment at
the exact same time it was my best
moment
because i took the hit and i changed
because of it it was my worst moment
because i went to a gunfight with a guy
that that had better weapons than i did
anyway why am i talking about my friend
larry elder well
he has been appointed to the commission
on the social status of black men and
boys by the administration
i only saw this reported by breitbart
but i just wanted to mention it
because larry is a great guy he has been
fighting the the pernicious racism
of the left and and the myths that they
sell you is true
and he's been doing it for decades he is
um he's been doing it alongside plenty
of other great people
he's a protege of course of thomas soul
who i've interviewed and we're still
working on getting that
second interview going there's just been
some logistical stuff um
but but larry is a great guy he's been
talking about how the
policies of big government of handouts
have been destroying the black family
and that that then leads to crime and
all sorts of other stuff and for years
he's been called
a a [ __ ] and a sellout and an uncle
tom and just the worst things possible
by the very people
who purport to be the tolerant ones so
i'm thrilled that
that he's going to be part of the
administration and that hopefully
um you know things that he's done that
candace owens
and brandon tatum have done with blexit
i i sense that
that the black community is waking up
you know if if any community
remove race remove anything else if
there's any group of people out there
based on
skin color or sexuality or gender or
anything else based on your immutable
characteristics
if you vote 95 for one party
year after year after year well they owe
you nothing
and that's actually in many ways what
the democrats have done
they keep getting the black vote and
then they do nothing
for trump has black started to to turn
some of that stuff around so hopefully
larry will be a big part of that
i think it's uh i think it's wonderful
and i'm always happy to talk
about my friend larry elder uh we're
just gonna do one more story for you i
know i'm running a little long today
but here in california in the last
couple of days uh
gavin newsom governor gavin newsom
probably the worst governor in all of
the union
although uh andrew cuomo is a pretty
close second
um he has signed a bill into law that
will establish a task force to study and
make rep
recommendations on reparations for
slavery
think about all of the things that that
are going on right now between covid
struggling economy the general state of
our discourse
everything else the idea
wait forget that forget that idea for a
second i'll say it a different way
our roads are crumbling here there are
homeless people all over the place there
are drugs on the streets there are
videos
i just saw one from last night downtown
l.a a mob of antifa people just
attacking stores and shutting down
streets
we got a lot of real problems and their
problems in 2020
and that is not to dismiss or belittle
uh how horrific and absolutely awful
slavery was
and it happened hundreds of years ago we
fought a war over it
as i keep saying i don't know of another
country that had
slavery at its inception that got rid of
slavery faster if you know a country
that did it faster than us then please
do let us know
uh we're insanely over taxed here
in california and particularly los
angeles and san francisco
and yet as i said the roads are
crumbling it's not like our schools are
good the entire thing is mismanaged but
what gavin newsom has decided to focus
on
right now of all things is another way
to tax us
to redis distribute money like it's
actually crazy
and and just a little bit on the on the
basic ideas of reparation
if if reparations are so moral and
they're so right and they're so good
what what's stopping all of the people
that support reparations from
giving up their money voluntarily and
why not make a list
and we're the public good guys who
voluntarily
give money and then find some
billionaires who will who are also
the good guys they're just great and
they want to give money away and they
want to do it voluntarily they don't
need the state to put the gun to your
head
to give away reparations money that that
doesn't seem very
moral what where are they if this state
is run by such
good great progressive tolerant moral
people
well then you'd think that 80 of the
state would just be voluntarily giving
their money right and then you get
billionaires to to double or match funds
or whatever it is
and yet that doesn't happen they seem to
think like how come gavin newsom how
much money have you given
for reparations you know um
this reminds me a little bit a couple
years ago i was at real time with bill
maher i was sitting in the audience
and i've been there i've been there a
few times by the way i don't even know
that i've even said i think i said this
publicly once i was supposed to be on
real time for
for the book and then it got cancelled
cause of covid
um and now it's like i don't even know
that i want to do it anymore i think
bill and i could have an interesting
conversation but like
it just that that show is starting to
feel irrelevant to me
um but anyway i was i was there and they
had michael
eric dyson on who is a lefty progressive
uh pundit thinker author whatever you
want to call it and they were doing
the bonus segment um what do they call
it overtime segment that's just for
youtube and they're talking about
reparations
and in essence i'm not quoting this
exactly what what he said is he's not
personally for reparations
but that you know you should buy a
computer
for i think he said for a young black
brother you should buy a computer
and i watched all of these liberals in
the audience i was particularly watching
this woman in front of me she was about
65 years old you know white liberal
and they're clapping they're clapping
like seals buy a computer
for a young black brother buy a computer
for them
and it's like this it's such a perfect
example of what these people do
that woman didn't buy anyone a computer
nobody in that audience bought anybody a
computer or even a freaking ipad
right like they just oh i applaud the
right thing so that i feel good because
i'm
a seal can i have that piece of fish
that's what they do and uh
that was a pretty decent impression of
that woman um
and it's just like enough of this so
look there are so many big problems that
we have to deal with this state is so
absolutely mismanaged no one in my
family owns slaves no ancestor that i
have owned slaves
there were people in my family that have
been victims of pogroms
people in my family have been victims of
the holocaust um everyone that came to
america so
what are we saying really like if you're
an irish immigrant and you
move and your grandparents or great
grandparents whatever it is moved here
because they were trying to avoid famine
or italian immigrants that moved here
with nothing and built something for
themselves did the american dream
that now you should be punished um just
doesn't make
any sense but but prove me wrong
progressives
show me how moral you guys are you guys
are moral you guys are good everybody
else is mean and greedy
so start doing it start a public
voluntary reparations fund
find a guilty lefty billionaire to to
match funds
i'm sure bill gates will do it right if
these are important things
find some celebrities that'll do it and
and go ahead and do it
and not only that because i know you
guys love lists you can have your list
of good guys and then you can have a
list of all of the bad people who won't
give reparations and then you can say
mean things about them like they're
racist and the rest of it
that seems like a great idea oh lordy
lordy okay guys i got a crazy day of
interviews ahead of me
um i assume by the time i come back
tomorrow trump will have got
covet again and then got rid of it again
and god knows what else could happen
i hope you feel a little bit better
about the news after watching this
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe by the way because we keep
getting emails that people are still
getting unsubscribed from our channel so
subscribe click that notification bell
and if you want to communicate with me
directly it's it's impossible
to do obviously in the youtube comment
section and twitter's becoming even more
difficult
join us at reubenreport.com alright
everybody have a great day and i'll see
you tomorrow